Hey kids, it's your old uncle Jay and
I'm not using 11 Labs this time. This
actually is it's me talking in the
microphone thing. It's uh it's gotten to
a point with the Parkinson's where
actually using 11 Labs is even harder
than talking. So, I'm going to talk if
that's okay with you. Hey gang, a lot of
you been around for a couple of years
and you remember two, three years ago
when uh we came out with a thing. What
was it? Autogra. Autogro. The cool thing
about autograph was it was an agent that
could create other agents and you and I
were all amazed by it, but the rest of
the world didn't pay much attention.
Well, this year they've come out with
Open Claw and everybody loves it because
Open Claw is an agent that can write
other agents. So, you and I were like
two years ahead of the curve there and I
just wanted to congratulate you for
that. Oh, and then later on about a year
later, I came out with the uh with the
thing that uh where our agents could
talk to each other like they had their
own Facebook. I forgot what it was
called, but then uh this year Molt Book
came out and everybody was like, "Oh,
Moltbook is so cool." So, you and I have
been years ahead of this thing all
along. And we're about to be years ahead
again as I present to you. Where is it
here? Uh oh, Jode Munch, my my latest
latest thing here. And um like it says
here, you you can save like nearly 100%.
I know you can't save 100% of your
tokens because you'd be getting nothing
done, but you can save like 99% of your
tokens on a lot of your calls using Jode
Munch. This is another one of those
things where two three years from now
they'll somebody will have this built in
to the LLMs, but for right now, it's
it's just you and me. So, JCode Munch,
you'll find it out at GitHub there. All
you got to do is do the git cloning
thing. And what is it's an MCP server. I
forget what MCP stands for. Model model
model context. I don't know. I'll cut
this I'll cut this part out later and
make myself sound smarter. Um, but you
can see here all I did was I just cloned
it down to a to an empty uh MCP's
directory. And installing it is pretty
easy. I've got it installed on all my
cloud instances both here at home and at
work. And if I do a listing of the MCP
servers here, you'll see JCode Munch is
installed. What JCode Munch really does
in a nutshell is um it's kind of like if
you need to look something up in the
encyclopedia
currently Claude like takes every volume
of the encyclopedia and reads it and
you're like, "Hey Claude, I just asked
you about pomegranates. All you needed
was the P volume." And by the way, if
I'm losing you kids, uh ask your
grandparents what the Encyclopedia
Bratannica was. In fact, go ahead, ask
them what books were because you're
probably not using those a lot anyway.
Um, what you could do is you can you
could just tell Claude to uh install the
MCP and it'll do it. You don't have to
worry about the big long read me in the
in the repo. You you can do it if you
want. This here is just uh this part is
just explaining to you what I did with
the what I did better with the uh
encyclopedia analogy. But um bottom
line, you install and run this bad boy
in Claude and you're going to get a lot
more bang for your buck and for what
they're charging for tokens over there
at Anthropic. It totally makes it worth
it. By the way, it's not just Claude
specific. any any uh anything you have
that uh that supports MCPs can use JCode
munch MCP and you can start saving tons
of tokens um right away. The uh primary
benefits of using it are spelled out
here if you want to if you want to hit
pause and read that. I don't like
reading things to people online. You
know that about me. I like people read
their own things. That way you can fast
forward if you want. Oh, here this is
cool. This is where I asked it to run a
quick fundamental. Now I'm reading to
you like I said I wouldn't but uh run a
quick fundamental test of demonstrating
the token savings and Claude will go
ahead and it'll it'll just write a short
little demonstration program and it'll
spit out what the token savings are and
it's doing that right here. It's going
to show you some stuff. Nobody really
knows what any of this stuff means. So
just if somebody's watching you just
look at it and nod and look smart. But
uh you just got to wait for Claude to
get done thinking and then then boom,
here it is. Here it is telling you that
instead of reading the whole file, it's
just going to read what it what it has
indexed. Um, oh, speaking of indexing,
uh, Claude will, uh, also as you make
code changes will will reindex the code
so it keeps working as you, as you work
on your programs. I'm making this sound
a lot more complicated than it is
really. Here's the bottom line. Install
JCode MunchMCP. Start saving mad tokens
with your uh, with your LLM programming.
Here's the uh the actual test results
from uh from the test that Claude wrote.
And you can see here that what am I
looking at? Oh yeah, here here I'm
telling it, okay, you went and installed
everything. Search for something
specific and contrast both the with
the Jcode Munch MCP and show us what the
difference is so that you, my faithful
and loyal audience, will be all uh all
impressed with with the JCode Munch
here. as I hope you are. I know it's
been a while since I made one of these
videos. Uh my health hasn't been all
that good. So, I appreciate you being
able to sit on your hands for a couple
of years while while I get my crap
together. Uh well, my crap is together
now. I have a note from my doctor and
everything. And uh here you'll see the
the uh Jcode Munch is running with the
MCP and it's grabbing the symbols that
it is indexed. And this it's all a lot
of words to say. What this shows you the
bottom line bottom line is that it used
700 tokens whereas if you didn't have
the MCP server would have used 3,850
tokens. So that's that's more and you
want less. So this does it 5.5 times
fewer tokens for this single lookup in
this. But don't don't take my word for
any of this. Go ahead and and download
the MCP server. Um install it and run it
against your own test. Run it against
some of your own code. run it. You can
pull down a repo if you want and try it
against that. You can try it against
something that you've got written on on
your machine. Um, it's going to work and
it's going to save you tokens. And
tokens is going to save you money. It'll
save you time, too, because obviously it
takes a lot less time to process 700
tokens worth of information than 3,850
tokens worth of information. I got this
uh site. I'll I'll link to this. This is
out of my gllus us site, but this is a
breakdown of uh of all the details with
the MCP server. If you're the geeky kind
who likes to drill down into things. I'm
the geeky kind who likes to show you the
stuff you can drill down into. But
between you and me, if if I was looking
at this, I would I probably wouldn't
read most. But um yeah, this
demonstrates the old way of doing things
versus J code Munch. And uh that's why I
titled it that, I guess. But look at
look at the contrast there. 141,000
tokens versus 480. Another 99.7%
savings. And um here's the actual data I
used from a I had a I had like a project
from work that I ran this against for
the stuff on this page. And uh yeah, it
just it just it just always uh it always
fascinates me when I ask it. Hey, hey,
man, how much did we just save doing
that? Plus, you're going to see that if
you if you're the kind like I am, I
monitor what my claud usage is
throughout the process because gez, I
asked I asked one query what what opus I
had a question on opus cost me $6 to
answer and that's when I got to work on
this on on this thing on indexing the
code and uh it's just it's just paid off
in volumes. Here's showing you real
dollar impact just just based on this
one program. If if I'm working on this
per year, I'm saving like 15 grand in in
token costs. Um, not that I'd be writing
that same program all year, but programs
like it, if I were doing that sort of
work day after day, which I do, um,
that's what I'd be saving in this case,
what I'd be saving my boss. So, there's
the wrap up on there. I I hope you'll
download it and thanks again for
listening.